i am a christian
but during the course of restoration i
have learned so much
attending these meetings should i be
re-baptized
not necessarily re-baptism is biblical
you find it in acts 19 1-7
where paul met 12 disciples who had
never heard of the holy spirit well how
can you be a child of god
not having heard of the holy spirit
romans 8 9 says if any man hath not the
spirit of christ he is what
none of his and so after paul instructed
them
he baptized them again re-baptism is
proper under certain circumstances one
you know in your heart you have left god
you know it and no one else does but you
know it
you have broken the covenant between you
and god to come back
you ought to re-establish the covenant
by the outward symbol
of baptism two
you left the truth and join some of the
church that does not preach the truth
you apostasize you deny christ's truth
like peter denied him
come back come back to the right of
baptism
or you were honestly a part of a group
that taught certain principles that were
not biblical you were honestly apart
did not know any better you came to
these meetings
and the noonday sun of light flashed
into your heart
and you realize that you have been way
off
you want to come onto the track of truth
you get baptized and i'll be making a
call at the end of the message for
baptism
and rebaptism you were baptized as a
child and really didn't know what you
were doing
now you know make the decision for
yourself
not for your parents who try to force
you to be baptized at 10.
those are generally the reasons why
people consider re-baptism
thank you god bless you